Você já teve a sensação de acordar
cansado ou cansada mesmo depois de
dormir a noite inteira, como se a
bateria do corpo tivesse viciado? Depois
dos 40 anos, isso fica cada vez mais
comum e não é frescura nem falta de
força de vontade. Em boa parte dos casos
é um problema mitocondrial. Suas usinas
de energia estão falhando. Nos últimos
anos, uma combinação especial começou a
se destacar na literatura científica PQQ
com coenzima Q10. Em um estudo recente,
a combinação dos dois aumentou a
densidade mitocondrial em torno de 37%
em poucas semanas e melhorou
significativamente a fadiga em adultos
entre 40 e 70 anos. Hoje eu vou te
explicar de forma direta como esse combo
funciona, porque tomar só com enzima Q10
muitas vezes decepciona. E qual é um
protocolo prático de suporte que eu
utilizo na prática clínica com doses,
forma correta e contexto de uso. Se a
sua energia despenca no meio da tarde,
se a memória está falhando e se você
sente que envelheceu 10 anos em dois,
fica comigo até o final.
Vamos começar com uma imagem simples.
Imagina que o seu corpo é uma cidade
enorme, tipo São Paulo. Cada célula é um
prédio. Dentro de cada prédio existem
pequenas usinas que mantém tudo
funcionando. Luz, elevador, ar
condicionado. Essas usinas são as
mitocôndrias. Quando você é jovem, esses
geradores são novos, limpos, funcionando
todo o vapor. É por isso que criança
corre o dia inteiro, dorme um pouco e no
dia seguinte tá zerada. Só que com tempo
e com estresse, malimentação,
sedentarismo, toxinas ambientais e
noites mal dormidas, duas coisas começam
a acontecer ao mesmo tempo. As usinas
que você já tem vão enferrujando pelo
estresse oxidativo e ao mesmo tempo a
quantidade de mitocôndrias por célula
diminui. Onde você tinha 10 geradores,
ficam dois tentando segurar a cidade
inteira. Resultado, você faz exame de
sangue, o laboratório escreve tudo
dentro da referência, o clínico diz que
tá tudo normal, mas você sente na pele
que não está, acorda cansado, tem nerva
mental, perde performance física e
profissional. E é aqui que entra a visão
funcional. Em vez de apenas empurrar
estimulante para você, a ideia é
restaurar a capacidade das suas usinas
de energia. E aqui aparece o erro que eu
vejo o tempo todo. A estratégia me
falaram que co enzima Q10 é bom, então
comecei a tomar por conta. A coesima Q10
é de fato fundamental. Dentro da
mitocôndria. Ela atua na cadeia
transportadora de elétrons, permitindo a
produção de ATP, que é a moeda de
energia do corpo. Sem com enzima Q10
suficiente, a geração de ATP despenca e
até aqui tudo certo. O problema é que a
COCED 10 sozinha é como um combustível
premium. Ela melhora o funcionamento da
usina que já existe, mas ela não manda
construir novas usinas. Se você tem
poucas mitocôndrias, seu parque
industrial está reduzido, entupa, com
combustível caro, não resolve o problema
de base. É aqui que entra o outro
personagem dessa história, o PQQ, a
pirrolo, quinolina, quinona. Eu gosto de
explicar assim, a cor que 10 é o
combustível, o PQQ é o arquiteto. Ele é
o sinal que diz ao seu DNA: "Construa
novas usinas de energia". O nome técnico
disso é biogênese mitocondrial. E
estudos clínicos comparando PQQ isolado,
Coquedia isolada e a combinação dos dois
mostra um padrão muito interessante. Os
grupos que usam só um dos suplementos
até melhoram, mas o grupo que usa o
combo costuma ter melhora bem maior na
fadiga, na disposição e até em
marcadoras objetivos como densidade
mitocondrial e inflamação. Em um dos
ensaios, por exemplo, o grupo combinado
teve melhora de mais de 40% nos escoros
de fadiga, enquanto os grupos isolados
ficaram ali na casa do 18 a 23%. Quando
mediram diretamente a densidade
mitocondrial em músculo, o aumento
expressivo apareceu só no grupo que usou
os dois juntos. Além disso, o combo PQ e
COQ10 reduziu marcadores inflamatórios
comit leucina 6 e peroxidação lipídica,
que é aquela ferrugem das membranas
celulares. Na prática, isso significa
inflamação crônica silenciosa e menos
dano cumulativo nas células. Vamos
detalhar um pouco mais cada peça dessa
engrenhagem.
A qualquer 10 existem duas formas
principais, o bikinona, que é a forma
oxidada, e o bikquinol, que é reduzida e
ativa. Quando você jovem saudável, o
corpo converte o bikquinona em o
biquinol sem grandes dificuldades. Só
que depois dos 40 e principalmente quem
usa estatinas, essa conversão começa a
falhar. Estatinas como atorvastatina,
cinvastatina, rosovastatina,
pitavastatina bloqueiam a mesma via que
produz qualquer 10 endógena. a
consequência direta da fadiga, mialgia,
que é dor muscular, perda de performance
muscular de forma geral. Em estudos com
usuários de estatinas, dose de 200 a 300
mg de coquez reduziram
significativamente as queixas de dor
muscular e cansaço. Por isso, para
suporte mitocondrial, eu prefiro
trabalhar com biquinol, que já está na
forma ativa, custa mais caro, sim, mas
você está pagando por algo que o corpo
aproveita de forma mais eficiente, em
vez de depender de uma conversão que
muitas vezes tá falhando. Já o PQ, além
da biogênese mitocondrial, via ativação
de PGC1 alfa, tem efeito neuroprotetor.
Estudos recentes sugerem que ele ajuda a
proteger neurônios contra estresse
oxidativo associado, por exemplo, a
proteínas como betamloide envolvidas no
Alzheimer. Isso não significa que PQQ
trata doença neurodegenerativa, mas abre
uma linha interessante prevenção de
declínio incognitivo, especialmente na
combinação com os pilares de estilo de
vida. Agora vamos ao que todo mundo quer
saber. Protocolo prático. Em termos de
dose, a faixa que mais aparece na
literatura para PQQ é de 10 a 20 mg por
dia. Abaixo disso, o efeito tende a ser
modesto. Acima disso, raramente se vê
benefício adicional proporcional ao
custo. Na minha experiência clínica, 20
mg manhã funciona bem para a maioria dos
casos em que o objetivo é suporte de
energia, cognição e envelhecimento
saudável. Para coquez na falma biquinol,
a faixa de 200 a 300 mg dia é a mais
utilizada em protocolo de suporte
mitocondrial em adultos acima de 40
anos, especialmente quem usa estatina,
tem fadiga persistente ou tem histórico
de doença cardiovascular. Doses menores
podem ser usadas para manutenção, mas
quando o objetivo é mudar o jogo, eu
prefiro começar na faixa mais robusta. E
como tomar a cor que é 10 liposolúvel
precisa de gordura para ser absorvida
adequadamente? Então o ideal é tomar
junto com uma refeição que contém a
gordura saudável. Ovos, abacate, azeite
de oliva extravirgem, oleaginosas. O PQ
tolera bem esse mesmo horário. Eu
costumo orientar o uso pela manhã junto
ao café da manhã, o que muitas pessoas
percebem um aumento de energia e se
forem tomar a noite podem ter
dificuldade de pegar no sono. Mas e por
quanto tempo? Em geral eu não avalio o
protocolo mitocondrial antes de 8
semanas. É o tempo biológico para
remodelar usinas, reduzir estresse
oxidativo e ajustar vias metabólicas.
Porém, muitos pacientes relatam melhor
objetivos de disposição, clareza mental
e tolerância ao esforço já a partir da
terceira ou quarta semana. Em termos de
segurança, tanto PQQ quanto 10 tem um
perfil muito favorável nas doses usuais.
Eventuais desconfortos digestivos
aparecem mais com doses muito altas de
comenzema Q10 a partir de 400, 600 mg em
pessoas sensíveis. No caso do PQ, existe
uma preocupação teórica em quem tem
histórico de cálculos renais de oxalato,
porque alguns metabólitos podem seguir
essa rota. Então, é um ponto de atenção.
Em usuários de anticoagulantes como a
vafarina, a coenzima Q10 pode, em alguns
casos, interferir no NR por ter
semelhança estrutural com a vitamina K.
Então esse grupo tem que ter
monitorização mais cuidadosa. Eu quero
ilustrar isso com um caso real e
simplificado. Pacientes de 52 anos no
executivo relatando fadiga debilitante
há mais de 2 anos, exames normais,
testosterona limítrofe, sono
aparentemente adequado, nada gritando na
investigação convencional. Iniciamos o
protocolo com ajuste de sono,
alimentação com redução forte de
ultraprocessados, introdução de
exercícios em zona dois três vezes por
semana.
mais supação com 20 mg de PQ e 300 mg de
biquinol ao dia. Em cerca de 6 semanas,
o relato subjetivo dele foi de melhor
50% na disposição, redução da neva
mental e maior tolerância a dias puxados
de trabalho. Em exames complementares,
marcadoras de estresse oxidativo, como
mal de aldeído, caíram de forma
significativa e a proteína ser reativa
ultrassensível também reduziu. Não foi
milagre, foi fisiologia respeitada. É
importante entender que esse combo não é
bala de prata. Se a pessoa dorme 4 horas
por noite, vive em hiperglicemia, açúcar
do sangue alto, come açúcar, começados,
farinha, o dia inteiro, não se movimenta
e acha que vai resolver tudo com duas
cápsulas, tá se enganando feio. O
excesso de glicose insulina, por
exemplo, bloqueia justamente as vias que
o PQ tenta ativar para estimular a
biogênese mitocondrial. Então é jogar
dinheiro fora. Se você realmente quer
extrair o máximo desse protocolo, três
pilares fazem muita diferença. Primeiro,
movimento. Exercício em zona dois,
aquela caminhada firme que você consegue
conversar, mas não consegue cantar. É um
dos estímulos mais poderosos para
aumentar a demanda energética saudável e
sinalizar pro corpo que vale a pena
produzir mais mitocôndrias. Segundo,
exposição controlada ao frio. Para quem
tolera banho mais frio no final da
chuveirada, por exemplo, o frio aumenta
a demanda de energia para manter a
temperatura e isso também conversa com
as vias de biogênis mitocondrial.
Terceiro, nutrição de base. Magnésio
como cofator enzimático em centenas de
reações, inclusive na produção de ATP.
Vitaminas do complexo B para alimentar o
ciclo de crebes. Ômega-3 para manter a
fluidez nas membranas mitocondriais.
Elcarnitina para transportar ácidos
grásos para dentro da mitocôndria. O PQQ
enzima Q10 são peças importantes, mas
fazem parte de um ecossistema. Resumindo
de forma prática, para suporte de
energia e envelhecimento saudável, um
protocolo típico pode ser algo como 20
mg de PQQ pela manhã, mais 200 a 300 mg
de coenzima Q10 na forma biquinol, junto
a uma refeição com gordura boa por pelo
menos 8 semanas. Em usuário de estatina,
esse suporte de cozema Q10 deixa de ser
luxo e passa a ser quase obrigatório do
ponto de vista bioquímico para minimizar
o dano mitocondrial. Se você sente que
sua energia caiu, que seu cérebro não
rende como antes e que a idade biológica
para estar correndo mais rápido do que o
calendário, olhar com o carinho paraas
suas mitocôndrias é um dos lugares mais
inteligentes para começar. Agora, se
você quer continuar nessa linha de
raciocínio, existe um outro nutriente
com papel muito especial no cérebro, o
magnésio tronato, uma das formas com
maior capacidade de atravessar a
barreira imatocefálica e atuar
diretamente em cognição e plastidade
sináptica. Eu tenho um vídeo específico
só sobre ele, onde eu aprofundo essa
questão da energia cerebral e memória.
Vale a pena você assistir em seguida
para conectar os pontos e para fechar
uma verdade incômoda. O YouTube e o
próprio ambiente regulatório me obrigam
a simplificar muita coisa aqui. Eu
preciso cortar detalhes de dose,
suavizar protocolos mais avançados e
evitar combinações of label que na
prática clínica fazem diferença real.
Então, dentro da comunidade fechada, eu
não preciso colocar esse filtro. Lá eu
compartilho exatamente os protocolos que
eu uso em consultório, casos de reversão
que pareciam impossíveis se eu contasse
insoltos, combinações avançadas e
fornecedores confiáveis, além
interpretação fina de exames e
atualizações de artigos linha por linha.
É praticamente ter acesso direto ao meu
raciocínio clínico. Temos dois níveis
nesse nosso grupo. Temos lives semanais,
materiais em PDF com dezenas de
protocolos e grupo exclusivo no
WhatsApp. Você deixa de ser um
espectador passivo e passa a fazer parte
do ciclo interno que está realmente
comprometido em dominar a medicina
funcional aplicada com profundidade, sem
superficialidade de rede social. Se isso
faz sentido para você, o botão seja
membro está aqui embaixo. Poucos têm
coragem de dar esse passo. A pergunta é:
você está entre esses poucos?
Agradecimentos especiais a nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Nível
dois, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Burtinho, Fernando Machado,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas, Luís Anselmo Neves, antes
da Doença, eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado. Ah.